I'm going to introduce pie in a way that
I don't think many people will have seen
before a friend of mine David Tong told
me about this and I think it's really
neat and it involved rolling balls at
each other our thought experiment
involves just two balls so there's a
small ball and we'll give it a mass
little m and there's a big bowl and
we'll give this mass a big n this is
actually a ten pin bowling ball which I
believe you stole now the idea is that
this ball the big ball is rolling with
some initial velocity and it hits the
little ball now the little ball moves
off and hits the wall and it bounces
elastically that means that when it
bounces it doesn't lose any kinetic
energy or any momentum it bounces back
meanwhile the big ball is carrying on it
hits the big ball again and then of
course it bounces back the big ball is
imparted a little bit of momentum to the
big ball that which is now slowing down
it goes back bounces again comes back
bounces back goes back and just keeps
doing this eventually the big ball slows
down enough that it stops and that the
next collision will begin to go back
okay so the system is the balls coming
in there's a number of collisions and
then the big ball eventually bounces and
goes back what's that got to do with the
pie the question is how many collisions
are there between the big ball and the
little ball before the big balls starts
going the other way okay it's as simple
as that
now as long as the mass of this big ball
is quite particular input in fact it's
given as in terms of the little mass
it's given us 16 times 100 to the power
n where I'm going to let this number n
vary so if n is zero the big ball is 16
times the mass of a little ball
if n is one the big bowl is 16 1600
times the mass of a little ball if n is
2 the the mass is a hundred and sixty
thousand times that have a little ball
so as long as you've got this very
particular mass then it turns out that
the number of collisions between the big
ball in the little bulb is the first n
plus 1 digits of pi so if N equals zero
then the number of so the big ball is 16
times the mass of the little ball
there'll be 3 collisions if n is 1 so
the big ball is 1,600 times that of the
little ball and so there will be 31
collisions if n is 3 there'll be 314
collisions if n is 4
they'll be 3141 collisions what's
remarkable about this I think is that
this is exact as long as n is an integer
that just can and you let it get bigger
and bigger and bigger you will get
exactly the number of the relevant
number of digits of pi so if this was 3
grams which and this is about four point
eight kilograms then there would be of
order thirty-one collisions so if I
scaled this up so that this was a
boulder of mass 480 kilograms then there
should be 314 collisions before the
boulder begins to go backwards I guess
these things around and have
circumferences and pi it's got nothing
to do with that which is fantastic
in fact if this was a point object with
a very massive and that was a point
object they would the same thing would
still apply it the fact that it's round
has nothing to do with it what is
important is that the collision is
elastic that it conserves energy and
conserves momentum but it could be any
shaped object
would do that so this has nothing to do
with circles this has nothing at all to
do with the circle of this ball and the
circle of this ball so that was a cube
or something else I think yes that would
be that would still work as long as
we're in the collision you conserved
energy and momentum okay okay here we go
let's try and make sense of a two balls
hitting each other and how we get PI out
of it let's just draw it again so the
idea is I have some surface and then I
have some wall at the end and I have a
little ball of mass little m and a a big
ball of mass big and initially the big
ball is moving with some velocity let's
call it U and it hits a little ball and
then what happens is the little ball
begins to go towards the wall meanwhile
the big ball carries on the big ball is
still moving the little ball hits the
wall and comes back and then it hits the
big ball again and so the little ball
bounces back hits the this wall bounces
back I mean each time the little ball
hits the big ball it transfers a bit of
its momentum over to the big ball and
the big ball will slow down and in fact
eventually the big ball will stop and
will begin to go the other way and what
we want to know is if that happens after
say P steps then how does P the number
of collisions depend upon the mass of
the big ball now what's important here
the only bit that I've had to throw in
that I must say Brady wasn't that
impressed with when I told him but still
I think it's neat is that there's a very
particular value for the big ball that
we're interested in the mass of the big
ball is 16 times a hundred to the power
N and the times the
mass of the little ball okay so if N
equals zero then the big ball is just 16
times the mass of the little ball if N
equals one then the big ball is 1,600
times the mass of the little ball and
you get the idea if N equals two then
the big ball is one is a hundred and
sixty thousand times the mass of the
little ball so rapidly it jumps up in
hundreds that's right not tense now in
each case you can ask how many steps how
many collisions of the big ball and the
little ball are there before the big
ball starts going in the opposite
direction in other words before the big
ball starts going backwards and the
result is remarkable so the number of
steps when N equals zero is equal to
three so the number of collisions is
three the number of collisions when N
equals one is 31 and the number of
collisions when N equals two is three
hundred and fourteen and it goes on it
goes on so that after for the case of a
general n the number of collisions is
that the first n plus 1 digits of pi pi
being 3.14 one dot and it's true for any
n so as n goes towards infinity
you just keep recovering the first n
plus 1 digits of pi is not it's not as
an expansion or anything like that it's
just the expression that you get
nothing to do with circles you can work
out this and the key ingredients that
you need which we do at school is you
need to remember that we have
conservation of energy in the collision
and conservation of momentum that's all
we need to make you self and when you've
got that you can work out the velocity
of the part of the big ball after M
collisions is possible to do that and
then the note which I'll call e UN okay
so after n collisions the big ball
velocity is U and and it turns out I can
work out what UN is UN after after a bit
of algebra UN in terms of this initial
velocity u naught is given by the
following it's given by this fairly
simple expression I'll tell you what X
is in a minute so don't panic Brady it's
given by this bits kind of irrelevant
but the bit that's important is the
following there's a cosine of this angle
theta so X is just the ratio of the
little mass to the big mass so it's
generally going to be very small you can
see that the the the largest it's going
to be is 1 over 16 and then it just gets
really really small very quickly so X is
generally much less than unity so cos
theta is equal to 1 minus x over 1 plus
X ok so everything is in terms of X this
ratio so how can I see when this ball is
going to start going in the opposite
direction and all I need to do that is
to remember what that's sorry that's cos
n theta I missed out an important end
there ok
that's cause of n theta not coz theta
all I need to do is is look at this
cosine function and we know what the
cosine looks like from our school days
cosine looks like the following it's got
as a function of some angle alpha that
cosine of alpha looks like this it goes
between 1 and minus 1 so and it changes
when alpha is PI by 2 it goes from
positive values to negative values when
alpha is PI by 2 there is ready PI's are
coming in so when n theta or alpha is
less than PI by 2 cosine is positive so
you and is positive that means it's
going in that direction but when n theta
gets bigger than PI by 2 cos n theta
goes negative so UN goes negative and
it's beginning to go in that direction
when n is zero is the integer part of 10
to the 0 times pi which is just pi and
so the integer part of that is 3 when n
is 1 the number of collisions is the
integer part of 10 times pi which is 31
and when n is 2 is the integer part of a
hundred times pi which is 314 and this
is true for any value of n